[Music]
so we had a chance to play the big team
battle mode from ecology modern warfare
the upcoming game this is Call of Duty
firmly taking a step in to eat maybe
battlefields lunch and that's exciting
so we played to n b10 we played 20 V 20
now it turns out that there's up to a
hundred players in this mode so full on
50 V 50 team battles
it is both literally huge and big for
this game so here's the thing with big
team battle I I like it a lot and I
think that's because I'm the person
they're going after people who came from
some other larger titles like
Battlefield who kind of feel like that
franchise has been drifting off for a
while it's not in a great place it's
been steadily going towards infantry
combat and honestly Call of Duty is just
gonna do infantry combat better than a
game like that ever will there's a lot
of things that they've done in modern
warfare that make big team battle more
exciting than if it was in a previous
title like black ops 4 for one gun
handling is way more realistic than it
was in the past couple iterations of
this game they've done a complete
overhaul of guns and the guns all have
pros and cons their attachment system
when you pick something it doesn't just
make your gun better it reduces idle
sway but it might make you slower at
running or it might make it slower for
you to ATS so when you're building a gun
you have to actually think about your
loadout for big team battle being an LMG
man myself means that if I take an LMG
I'm gonna want to sit on sort of the
outside of the map as opposed to some of
the interior gnarly spaces we're all
need to ATS faster however I can make
build outs with faster ATS speed that
might say slow down my run speed so
there's pros and cons and you really
have to think about it when you're
building a gun in this game and I like
that so much I love the fact that you
can screw up a gun build because that's
fun that means that there's enough room
there for you to do interesting things
so how the game plays we played on this
Anaya palace map they're trying to get
rid of the three lane design and they're
trying to make the game focused around
what they call power points what they
really mean are basically buildings you
controlling buildings the palace map
played really interesting there's a
central Palace as it is in the name and
there's a courtyard and we had a couple
of matches where the one team or the
other controlled that courtyard and the
entrance points to that court you are
really well and that made a huge
difference in that match so that's where
the new killstreak system is very
important and also our big team battle
continues to be exciting for me so you
tend to break those stalemates with
killstreaks I drove around in a tank for
a while which was a you know something
that was in I believe World War two but
it's a killstreak this time around and
it's crazy to think you know I'm
suddenly driving a tank around in a big
team battle mode in Call of Duty the
white phosphorus which everybody's been
kind of talking about a lot it's
actually very useful in this mode
because if an enemy team is holding that
courtyard and you just simply can't
break through you know the white
phosphorus has a mechanic it actually
blankets the whole area of the map and
starts choking the enemy team and it
makes it easier for your team to move
into that area
I think big team battle brings a lot of
meaning and purpose to your weapon
builds your overall load outs and your
kill streaks that you take with you
there's also things like something like
a tactical insertion flare which becomes
now more important because on a bigger
map you need to choose where you spawn
grenade interceptor just because there's
more people throwing grenades the
overall feel of big team battle was it's
oddly Call of Duty feeling just because
there's so many people on the map at
once doing so many kill streaks and so
many different combat engagements but it
also feels like a great step for call of
duty one thing to keep in mind is this
is just one mode this game still has
plenty of core modes in 6v6 and it also
has the 2v2 gunfights so you will still
find what you're looking for from one of
those but this one's exciting I think
it'll pull in a wider audience
you
[Music]
[Applause]